quand je participe à une rencontre
sociale et que je dis ce que je fais
dans la vie je dis que je suis donc
auteur-metteur en fin de bons comédiens
etc
souvent les gens vont me dire ah oui le
théâtre ah oui on adore son hip hop mais
on adore ce ou encore au oui oui le
théâtre oui j'allais quand j'étais jeune
avant c'est vrai c'est vrai on y voit
pas assez souvent et je me demande
toujours pourquoi les gens disent ça
parce que je suis moi peut-être par
politesse pour me dire j'y vais pas mais
je considère que c'est important ce que
vous faites
bravo continuez ou ou encore une sorte
de de culpabilité culturel parce que le
le théâtre partie de ce qu'on appelait
autrefois la grande culture et que c'est
bien dans la vie de l'auteur de temps en
temps comme c'est bien d'aller au
concert comme c'est bien d'aller au
musée
je me dis toujours si je suis dit que
j'étais potier et que je fabriquais des
petits clans pour l'argile jeu pas sûr
que les gens diraient ah oui la patrie
c'est vrai on devrait en acheter plus
souvent
le thème des conférences ted cette année
c'est renaissance au carré connaissance
d'eux
si on se réfère à leur naissance un seul
est caractérisé ces trois choses
essentiellement s'est tout à coup d un
paquet de découvertes scientifiques un
intérêt pour la science pendant cette
période là accompagné de développement
technologique le qui ont des incidences
pour la vie de l'époque et en
contrepartie il ya eu toute la
redécouverte des auteurs de l'antiquité
grecque et romaine donc la rencontre
entre la sagesse antique et les
découvertes de l'époque ont donné
naissance au nouveau mouvement
philosophique c'est appeler l'humanisme
pas comme son nom le dit c'est l'être
humain qui était au coeur de cette
philosophie là c'est vrai aujourd'hui on
peut dire que notre notre monde dans
lequel on vit une sorte de renaissance à
cause du foisonnement qui a des
découvertes scientifiques absolument
extraordinaires qui sont presque à
chaque semaine des innovations
technologiques formidable qui touche
notre vie tous les jours mais n'y a pas
vraiment de textes fondateurs de texte
fondamental qui nous relie tout le monde
et on peut pas dire non plus que l'être
humain est au centre de ces
développements lo nonm eux mêmes plutôt
l'impression que l'être mais
tranquillement pousser de plus en plus à
la marge et que tout ce qu'il fait c'est
qu'ils pédalent de plus en plus pour
rester dans le train en marche et cette
marginalisation de l'être humain là pour
moi a commencé il ya un siècle
à peu près au début du 20e siècle quand
les les chercheurs les physiciens sont
mis à s'attarder à l'atome pour
comprendre comment ça fonctionnait et le
noyau les protons et neutrons les
électrons tout ça même en ayant eu et
ont compris qu à l'intérieur du noyau se
cachait une somme formidable d'énergie
et cette formidable colossal énergie là
s'est exprimé quarante ans plus tard à
hiroshima et nagasaki dans une version
assez tragique
donc évidemment ça détruit les villes ça
a mis fin à la guerre avec le japon mais
si on regarde ça avec un peu de
perspective c'est comme si longue de
choc de ces explosions là s'était
répercutée avec les années dans toutes
les sphères de notre société
dans les années 60 par exemple avec
l'arrivée des boomers qui sont nés juste
après la fin de la guerre justement donc
arriver des boomers le mouvement hippie
la contre-culture alors si toutes les
valeurs familiales et morales ont
commencé à s'effriter
c'est aussi l'époque de la montée du
féminisme et le le le le mur patriarcale
où commençait à s'effriter
c'est les guerres de libération en
afrique et là c'est tout le colonialisme
qui s'est effondré complètement dans
cette nasse et année là dans les années
80 avec l'arrivée du libéralisme
économique c'est la frontière la notion
même de frontières qui est devenu un peu
obsolètes parce que ça faisait écran à
l' échange de biens et de capitaux même
le mur de berlin qui séparait le monde
occidental en 2 s'est effondré dans les
années 80 pour le sait justement
circuler librement biens et capitaux
donc quand on regarde le monde dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui tout ce qui
constituait le noyau dur de notre
société qu'il ya cinquante ans comme moi
j'étais enfant tout ça a explosé
les valeurs morales familiale l'autorité
du père dieu la religion la patrie
toutes ces choses là qui constituait
notre ciment finalement tout ça explose
et maintenant la société c'est plus
seulement un corps communs qui parle à
peu près d'une même voix mais un
ensemble d'atomes d'électrons peu livre
qui se promène comme son excès goutines
par petits centres d'intérêts au début
du 21e siècle
à la fin du xxème début du xxième
c'était toute l'époque du virtuel qui
était arrivé alors tout est en train de
se virtualise et nous nos
correspondances avec les gens sont
virtuels les photos sont virtuels sont
numérisés le commerce est virtuel et
tous sans vote ou migrent tranquillement
dans le grand cloud va bientôt tout nous
toutes nos données seront dans le grand
cloud ou et le théâtre la dame me direz
vous donc je fais encore un petit
ricochet par la science au milieu des
années 90 les neurosciences ont
découvert ce qu'ils ont appelé les
neurones miroirs dont ils n'auront tout
le monde sait ce que c'est c'est les
cellules nerveuses qui transmettent les
impulsions nerveuses du cerveau au
marbre qui fait que je peux bouger mes
bras et piétiné un peu comme ça devant
vous sur scène
les neurones miroirs eux ne vont pas
induire un mouvement mais un potentiel
de mouvement alors si je fais ceci de
bambou comme ça et qu'on mettait des
capteurs sur vos muscles ici on verrait
que vos muscles avouons une impulsion de
faire ce mouvement vous l'avez pas fait
réellement mais de façon microscopiques
oui vous l'avez fait votre cerveau
envoyé un petit signal les neurones les
neurones miroirs envoyé un petit signal
si je fais ça peut-être pas besoin de
capteurs pour le constater
et c'est une émotion qu'on retrouve
aussi de temps en temps au théâtre donc
alors
dans les neurones miroirs sont sentis on
a découvert c'est que quand quelqu'un
bouge devant moi ça bouge aussi à
l'intérieur de moi et les neurones
miroirs sont pas seulement sensible aux
mouvements mais aussi aux émotions
si par exemple on met la photo de
quelqu'un qui est en colère tous les
muscles de mon visage qui bouge quand je
suis en colère vont être sollicités et
ce qui est encore plus intéressant c'est
que plus un espèce est apparenté à moi
plus les neurones miroirs qui seront
sensibles donc je serai plus sensibles
au visage d'un homme en colère ou visage
d'un show en colère est plus sensible
aux champs écoles en colère qu'un ver de
terre en colère je sais que la colère du
ver de terre est assez difficile est
subtile à décoder met donc alors ce qui
est très important c'est que ces
neurones là vont permettre très utile
pour l'apprentissage parce qu'on apprend
en mimant mis mes tisanes aux parents
les plus vieux autour de nous pour le
groupe la vie de groupe aussi omis
menottes gambettes comme aux hôtes ont
même on est on est tous ensemble et on
bouge à peu près pareil mais aussi les
compense les les chercheurs pensent
qu'ils sont grandement responsables de
l'empathie le sentiment d'empathie qu'on
éprouve les uns envers les autres
parce que si tu as it sur une émotion
devant moi en tout petit je ressens
microscopique mans mais je la ressens
cette émotion et il ya un échange comme
ça il ya même un chercheur qui a pris
sur les neurones gandhi alors moi
j'étais très content d'apprendre ça fait
découverte là parce que ça corroborait
l'intuition de jacques lecoq jacques
lecoq sera pédagogue français qui a
ouvert une école de théâtre dans les
années 50
chez qui j'ai étudié au début des années
80 et toute sa pédagogie est à baser sur
cette aide sur cette intuition là que
l'être humain fondamentalement est un
mineur ont même les autres et tout ce
qui bouge à l'extérieur deux mois bouge
aussi à l'intérieur de moi et à partir
de ça je peux faire du théâtre alors
j'étais content d'apprendre quand même
de théâtre parce que je me disais que
j'avais pas investi tout cet argent dans
les faits donnée dans les frais de
scolarité pour rien mais aussi parce que
s'il n'y a pas de grandes oeuvres
fondatrice fondamentales qui nous relie
tout le monde il ya toujours nos corps
qui sont là et que nos corps sont
porteurs de sens sont porteurs
d'intelligence sont porteurs d'émotions
et maintenant c'est prouvé
scientifiquement quand on raisonne les
uns dans les autres
qu'est ce qui se passe au théâtre
finalement c'est qu'on s'envoie la fin
de la journée dans une salle est
volontairement on s'assoit on se tait et
on écoute on regarde une histoire qui
est racontée devant nous et qui résonne
en nous alors on fait comme dans les
sociétés primitives à la fin de la
journée quand autour du feu les
chasseurs racontent comment ils ont
débusqué la gazelle ou après une grosse
journée de déménagement qu'on te connais
tu as l'air et d'un camarade et à la fin
de la journée autour d'une grosse pizza
on raconte les méfaits de la journée ou
ce qui était arrivé quand on a caressé
les coupables vin etc où m après une
grosse réunion autour d'un café on va
débriefer notre réunion alors le théâtre
essentiellement c'est ce qui fait si qui
débris la vie et c'est d'autant plus
vrai qu'avec le théâtre contemporain
maintenant et non seulement le cadre
contemporain prend toutes sortes de
formes et peut parler de tous les sujets
alors je prends l'exemple sur ma propre
compagnie puisque c'est celle que je
connais mieux le terreau niveau parking
on vient de terminer en fin de semaine
un spectacle qui parle des émotions mais
de la chimie du cerveau c'est les
émotions la chimie du cerveau
la dépression les pharmaceutiques dans à
peine trois semaines justice dans la
salle à côté ont offert un spectacle qui
va parler de clonage de génétique de
leur du rapport père fils à travers tout
ça au printemps à l'aborder on va faire
un spectacle qui va parler de la
recherche médicale du cancer de la mort
de la poésie
alors on peut parler d'à peu près tout
maintenant et parce qu'on est en
résonance en empathie avec ce qui se
passe sur scène ça peut amener les gens
vivent des choses très très très forte
je me rappelle en 1994 j'ai écrit une
pièce qui s'est fait ça plait ça peut
toujours mais qui s'appelait j'en ai les
anges alors c'était l'histoire du québec
dans cette personne à québec des années
40 50 et il y avait une adolescente dans
l'histoire qui qui avaient un bébé et
parce qu'elle était tout jeune on avait
décidé de le donner en adoption à
pouvait pas se résoudre à faire ça donc
elle avait tué son bébé
le lendemain la comédienne qui jouait le
personnage reçoit une lettre à son nom
et c'est une dame dans la soixantaine
qui racontait que elle-même étant de
l'essence avait eu un enfant qu'elle
avait que la famille avait décidé de
donner en adoption et en assistant la
pièce tout à coup ce souhaite remonter
en l et ce qu'elle avait réalisé ce que
depuis toutes ces années là elle n'avait
jamais s était toujours restée accrochée
au bébé et que ça avait créé
inconsciemment toutes sortes de
problèmes chez elle et que en voyant ces
pièces là en prenant conscience de soi
tout à coup et le laisser aller
finalement ce bébé là alors c'est pas
toujours des expériences aussi forte
bien sûr mais je sais moi pour parler
les spectateurs après les
représentations de soi je sais que ma
paye maintenant la science mais elle
prouve 6 passes toujours vraiment
quelque chose entre l'histoire qui est
racontée et les spectateurs qui nous
aide à comprendre quelque chose sur
notre vie donc elle est juste finalement
l'intuition que les gens ont quand ils
disent oui oui on devrait aller au
théâtre plus souvent elle est juste
parce que et surtout dans les périodes
dans lequel on vit où le virtuel
le numérique envie de plus en plus
toutes les sphères du divertissement de
plus en plus les productions culturelles
parce que aussi longtemps qu'on sera
touché ému par des gens comme nous qui
racontent devant nous des histoires qui
parlent de nous on restera encore en
contact les uns avec les autres et plus
important encore on sera de plus en plus
en contact avec notre part d'humanité
profonde en nous qui est cette petite
lampe d'argile qui éclaire la nuit qui
nous entoure
merci beaucoup